I protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using Aura I get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so I
can fix the problem fast try Aura free
for two weeks using my link below
it increasingly seems like it is very
dangerous legally to represent the
failed former president Donald Trump
more of Donald Trump's lawyers May soon
need representation themselves and as
we've said many times before the real
meaning of Maga is making attorneys get
attorneys there's a very interesting
article in Salon legal experts say Trump
lawyers may need their own lawyers after
doj filing the justice department on
Tuesday said in a filing that Trump and
his legal team likely tried to conceal
classified documents after being hit
with a grand jury subpoena the 36-page
filing came in response to Trump's
dubious request to appoint a special
Master to review the Seas documents
details the doj's evidence of
obstruction of justice the doj filing
suggests Trump and his team
may have tried to mislead investigators
when Trump attorney Christina Bob signed
a document affirming all classified
documents sought by The Archives have
been returned as you now well know and
as was made clear in this viral
photograph taken on Donald Trump's
cheesy Casino rugs in his apartment uh
in Florida there are plenty of secret
and top secret documents that were there
so yes making attorneys get attorneys
and sometimes I start to wonder don't
they know that the FBI is going to take
pictures and that they're going to film
and that it may come out and you can't
just come out and say we gave all the
documents back there are no such
documents the
declassification component which many of
Trump's lawyers have focused on is a
distraction it's not actually relevant
in most of the statutes that are at
issue here and there were lies told to
the FBI by Trump and his attorney
attorneys about having the documents
regardless of the classification status
that's what matters and as I told you
before nobody's been charged with
anything yet but the potential criminal
penalties for some of these things are
we're talking about decades okay as as
maximum hypothetical penalties the
classified documents and the
non-classified documents are government
documents Trump did not have the
authority
to have them at his house the doj makes
it clear they belong not to an
ex-president just because he took them
with them and um seemingly doing
self-inflicted damage as well just as a
reminder we looked at this clip on
yesterday's show one of Trump's
attorneys Alina Haba putting herself at
the scene of the crime saying I was
there I know exactly what was where yeah
nowhere what what's happened is now
they've put this picture out so that you
would assume and I am somebody who has
been and the Press loves to talk about
this especially today I'm somebody that
has been in his office I've seen it this
is not the way his office looks they
give you this appearance that you walk
in and there's these top secret
documents just thrown about a b they
don't understand something could be
marked top secret could be Mark
classified the presidential records act
he would have said this is Declassified
it doesn't get a new marking all the
time he's left the office it is a
complete public spectacle and I'm not
really going to stand by it anymore he
won't stand by it and yet she may also
soon be a defendant these people truly
are pathetic in the that this is the
absolute best that they can come up with
and so legal Jeopardy is going Beyond
Trump here and of course there's a
question as to if and when anybody will
be charged and even if they are will
there be consequences but Trump's own
lawyers increasingly in legal Harm's Way
and also the right wing simply can't get
on the right talking point this is
really just kind of funny it's a comedy
of errors Ronnie Jackson who is now a
republican congressman from Texas used
to be Trump's lawyer he's the I'm sorry
Trump's doctor he's the doctor who
claimed that Trump is six feet three
inches tall and weighs 239 pounds
neither is believable look at pictures
of trump next to Obama or Tom Brady and
you'll very quickly realize that that
doctor Ronnie Jackson went on Fox News
and he went back to I don't even know
that this uh evidence was really there
I'm not even sure kind of alluding again
to the FBI plan of the evidence now the
problem is they've already moved many
steps beyond that deflection Ronnie I
guess not getting the memo does no one
trust the FBI or the doj anymore I don't
trust him any further that I didn't grow
that entire
who knows what they got out of there I
don't trust these people at all they
came in they spent nine hours in there
they walked in with backpacks they
kicked out the president's lawyers the
Secret Service agents who knows in my
opinion I'm just going to say if they
told me that they found something I
wouldn't know that they actually found
it there or if they just said they found
it there I don't trust this organization
anymore the American people don't it may
all be planted and of course the problem
is that Donald Trump and others already
moved on and they went to well the stuff
was there but it was Trump's right to
have it or the stuff was there but Trump
Declassified it or it would whatever
they moved on from this talking point
weeks ago and Ronnie Jackson seems to be
very very far behind on that at this
point in time he he's off in a couple
weeks behind and again when you remember
he told us Trump weighs 239 and a 6'3
not a particularly believable guy all
right I know that some people don't like
that I'm taking such pleasure
in the failures of Donald Trump's social
media platform truth social essential
but I am taking significant pleasure in
what appears to be its imminent failure
there is yet another obstacle now for
Donald Trump's truth social it has been
barred from Google Play
over content moderation issues this is
an article from the hill
content moderation concerns are holding
up the approval of former president
Trump's truth social app on Android
devices according to a Google
spokesperson truth social CEO Devin
Nunes claimed last week that the Android
version was ready and waiting
however a Google spokesperson said that
the platform lacks effective content
moderation needed to meet the Google
Play app store's terms of service the
spokesperson said quote on August 19 we
notified truth social of several
violations of standard policies in their
current APP submission and reiterated
having effective systems for moderating
user-generated content is a condition of
our terms of service for any app to go
live on Google Play
they don't actually have the proper
content moderation so this this is so
funny because first of all they brand
themselves as a free speech app
saying conservatives are being silenced
there is such demand for a real free
speech app turns out conservatives
weren't that eager to get untruth Social
and it also turns out it wasn't really a
free speech app if you would go on Truth
social and you would talk about the
January 6th hearings you would get
banned if you made negative comments
about Trump to some degree you would get
banned we started seeing all these
different things but at the same time
the little content moderation that there
is isn't even enough to meet the
standards required to be on the Google
Play store which is like the i i the um
I don't have an apple it's the I store
the iPhone iTunes Store I guess it's
called
um and it is just every every aspect of
this is delightful so my expectation is
very soon truth social will be done it
might remain up to make it appear as
though it's not really done but they've
stopped paying vendors and oh they're
web hosting company 1.6 million dollars
as of about a week ago uh there's almost
no interaction on the platform as a as a
goof for a little while I was posting on
it but about a week ago I stopped
because it became clear there's just no
point it's it's a dead sight even Trump
sometimes only gets a couple thousand
interactions to his posts and the best
part about all of this is they're
failing on their own no nobody's
censoring them they are just not
attracting people and it's all flailing
it's all pathetic it's all hilarious and
I love absolutely every second of it we
are going to be off on Monday for the
federal Labor Day Holiday and then we're
going to be back really through the
election quite frankly
um there's Columbus Day coming up but
beyond that we're going to be here
through the election we are going to be
covering debates we will be covering
election results we will be covering
covering rallies and so many other
things and I'm so glad to have everybody
with us and we're soon going to have
more news about the launch of the new
YouTube channel and so many other
different things of course you can
always sign up at
joinpakman.com Alex Jones finds it
predatory that is a freaking Predator
right there but members love it members
love the bonus show they love all of it
and I encourage you to sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code big voting22 to get yourselves a
discount and we will be back right after
this extraordinarily short break
imagine this scenario you try logging
into your email account to see that your
password was changed a few hours ago
except you didn't do it and then you get
notifications of activity from your bank
and from your credit cards but you
didn't do any of it that is what
identity theft is like it can happen
very quickly and if you don't act fast
it can get worse we've dealt with this
at the David packman show you can find
videos about it and that's why I protect
myself now using Aura our sponsor Aura
is Identity Theft Protection fraud
monitoring password management and an
antivirus all in one easy to use app
Aura will monitor the dark web for your
emails passwords and Social Security
numbers and we'll send you alerts
quickly to your phone and email Aura
also gives you near real-time alerts on
suspicious credit inquiries like if
someone was opening a loan or a credit
card in your name and if you sign up at
aura.com Pacman you will get a free
two-week trial which you can use to see
if your login credentials have been
leaked online I would want to know that
right away use the link below the David
packman show is a community supported
podcast and YouTube show and all of
those other things that it is you can
sign up at joinpakman.com to become a
member memberships are a big big deal
the bonus show
is bad yeah the bonus show is one of the
great benefits and I encourage you to
sign up let's hear from people people in
the audience because without you I'm a
guy in a room with a microphone and
everybody is sad and everything is bad
you can call in Via Discord at
davidpackman.com
slash Discord and we are going to start
today with a very very special person
we're starting with Steve from the Bay
Area Steve welcome what's going on
and Steve is gone oh boy already having
a problem let's go to Tomas from my
birth city of Buenos Aires Tomas
bienvenido
oh boy
hello
Tomas you have a configuration problem
where whatever audio device you have
selected doesn't actually work because
you're unmuted
and we will give Thomas one last
opportunity to resolve his audio issues
hmm people are telling me they can hear
Tomas so let's see maybe this is my
audio settings let's see if I can fix
that
uh
uh let's see here
Tomas are you with me
I am oh wow welcome welcome that was my
fault I apologize
hello once again pleasure
um I'm not going to ask you how you're
doing so
because you said not to thank you yeah
Noni I'm doing fine today we don't need
everybody to ask me how I'm doing tell
me what's going on with the currency
these days in Argentina
when is it when is it ever different
we're doing badly got it and what at
this point is everybody operating on the
blue dollar
everyone's operating on just
not operating again okay fair fair well
what's on your mind today
um you know the whole uh
Luciani thing that's going on in
Argentina no I have not been following
it
basically I don't know if you remember a
long time ago we had the
what's it called the prosecutor nieceman
who killed himself supposedly supposedly
yes yeah
well there's a new prosecutor that is
going to prosecute Chris Christina oh
yes yes no I didn't know his name but I
have been following that yeah
and our president Alberto he said
I hope he doesn't kill himself like the
last one did right that would be really
sad if that happened on TV
uh he said that on on Dane right
yeah yeah
it's completely insane now you know I I
have friends and some of them I'm
friends with on Facebook who are
christinistas they just love Christina
they have been silent since this
happened now I'm sure that down there
some of them are being very loud but
like how are they defending this
basically there's like all of regolita
is just swarming with Chris with like
krishnaristas and stuff like everyone's
just in the streets like all day long
but what's been the reaction to that
comment I hope he doesn't kill himself
it's ignored completely okay yeah that
makes sense that's very trumpian
actually
yeah it is it is do you think do you
think she's going to end up in prison in
all seriousness
I don't I don't think so probably not
right yeah it just doesn't seem like no
they never do they never do exactly
exactly wow well
all right she did it would be there
would be like riots and stuff
yeah you know Lindsey Graham said if
Trump gets indicted there will be riots
just imagine what will happen if
Christina ends up in prison
yeah people would a lot of people would
die yeah any new type of Empanada I
should be aware of
oh uh
oh that's interesting that's sort of
American isn't it it it really is it's
my favorite time now wow and it's just
like is it a normal hot dog or is it
like a nice sausage
no it's a normal hot dog just cut up and
put it that's really sad it's really sad
to see Empanada culture go into the
direction of hot dogs
I mean it's delicious so oh God I can't
complain all right my friend well thank
you for the call
see ya thanks ciao that was geez that's
that's depressing let's go to JWR from
Atlanta Georgia JWR welcome
great to be here again
um
I was going to ask okay I guess my
general question was how
um I think I've had a phrase this
um how how what's the right what's the
what's the right balance of how much of
how much attention we should be getting
to this whole thing regarding Trump and
the investigation because although
although he's not as much of an F
although he is not as much of an active
threat as he was like say a year a year
or two when there was a community of
getting when there was a chance of
getting reelected there is still there
is still the possibility that we might
just blow like just blow him blow him
off ignore it pretend that just act as
though he's not an issue anymore so like
what's the right balance we should be
what's the right balance to strike well
listen if it's not made clear if it has
to be made clear that what Trump did is
humiliatingly Criminal and unacceptable
because if everybody just stays quiet
about it and doesn't talk about the fact
that you know he's got dumps of
documents all over his apartment then it
actually makes it more plausible that
voters will vote for him again in 2024.
they really really need to be brutally
humiliated into not even considering
supporting the guy in 2024. now I know
that there are Republicans who are
saying oh the Mar-A-Lago raid is the
best thing that could have happened to
Trump I've seen no real evidence of that
so far
no well no not so far hopefully it's not
that way
also
um am I only allowed one question well
it depends what it is let's hear the
second one
um do you think that there is a chance
that better men could potentially screw
up the lead he has over over Dr Oz in
the senate race in Pennsylvania but so
far things look good but do you think
there do you think that there is a
chance that they might potentially screw
this up in like the debates yeah I mean
listen you can always screw it up it's
it's looking very solid for fetterman
right now but of course he could screw
it up let's just hope it doesn't happen
oh of course not I mean I'm not saying
that I think he is going to I think he
is in a very good place but not like put
it this way he is winning but he has not
won yet absolutely and I I just yes and
I I just hope that he that that his
campaign which so far has done a pretty
decent job continues to keep it up and
doesn't and doesn't uh I guess
uh blow the blow the three to one leader
they have so far yes I have not seen
that it's three to one but I appreciate
the phone call very very much I believe
what you're referring to is that he's
estimated to have a 75 chance of winning
but not that he's going to win 75 to 25.
let's go next where are we going next
let's go to Alex from New York Alex
welcome
hi David hi
so I know we're looking ahead at the 22
2022 midterms but I just wanted to ask
about 2024 so because I know we've got
mixed signals about Joe Biden running
for re-election yes uh what is the
possibility do you think he could beat
Trump and do you think he'll run for
re-election too early to say and I don't
think he's going to run for re-election
on whether he could beat Trump I mean is
Trump under indictment is Trump still
popular with Republicans when the time
comes I just think it's an empirical
question we don't have the answer to my
opinion is that Joe Biden is not going
to run for re-election I know that
that's controversial among my audience
but I don't I don't believe Biden will
run for re-election
what reasons do you have for that I
think he's just not interested in it I
think that uh he was so sort of he's a
transitional president hopefully out of
trumpism I think his age is a factor I
just don't know that uh it's something
that is of interest to him although I
have to say with the Resurgence that the
by the rebirth that the Biden
Administration has had in the last two
months I'm feeling less confident about
that but I still think if you give me
just like an even odds BET right now I
say Biden does not run I would be glad
to be wrong
all right well thank you David thank you
there's Alex from New York with a very
precise question just a reminder if
you're holding on to chat with me if
your name in The Waiting Lobby is
anything other than your name and where
you were calling from you will not be
called on so people who have nicknames
listed people who are using parentheses
to get to the top of the list all these
different things you will not be called
on the only format that is valid is for
example Mike from Baco Mike is next Mike
what is is Baco how it's pronounced I've
never heard of that
uh it's actually Bakersfield oh it's
just like a nickname for Bakersfield I
did not know that Mike from Bakersfield
welcome
thank you yeah actually a big fan
um yeah so my question would be
um how um what is your favorite
okay what is my favorite what
and they're gone all right very good man
we are we are really struggling with
some of these calls today let's go next
to Kevin from San Diego California since
we dropped a call from Bakersfield I
figure we'll go nearby what's going on
there Kevin you know San Diego is
clearly a much Superior place to
Bakersfield we at least pick up the
calls and I don't think I'm going to
leave anytime soon in my experience I
have to agree with you no offense to
people from Bakersfield but having been
to both I have to say my preference is
San Diego but no offense to anybody
well yeah no that that's very uh very
diplomatic take if you dated thank you
um I wanted to go a little bit away from
uh politics right now I wanted to know
um do you have a particular like workout
routine or otherwise uh you know way to
stay in shape
well I basically will alternate cardio
and
um uh uh weight training essentially uh
for cardio I Pro I like running and
biking and then in terms of weight
training you know I'll find some
circuits online and then like when I was
going to the gym before the pandemic I
would do them there uh but then you know
during the pandemic
yeah are you still out of the gym I'm
still out of the gym but you know I'm
I'm starting to look at going back
because with my schedule I'd be able I
just you know I used to get colds all
the time I haven't had a cold in so long
and I think part of it is
spending time at the gym is a great
place to get yourself a cold you know
and um I think if I went back I would be
able to go at a time that it's very very
quiet and I think it might be a good
thing there's just so much more
equipment you know
yeah there is a lot going on at the gym
it's uh it's worth it for more detailed
things if you're kind of basic on
whatever you're doing like you can just
lift some weights or have like a you
know oh in terms of the thing do you
have like a stationary bicycle or
treadmill or something or do you like
actually run outside I run outside I
bike outside all right well that's the
way to do it it really is it really is
uh that's about it David should I be
taking some kind of protein powder do
you think or am I probably okay uh
I mean I'm not an expert on any of these
kind of things I think it's like
basically you can get really detailed on
the things that you're doing with any
kind of Fitness stuff but
um if you are at the level where you're
not seeing yourself like improve a lot
over what you're doing regularly you can
always add something else so like
protein powder at that point is probably
a good idea but if you're just kind of
if you're fine where you are you
probably don't need it yeah no I'm not
going to use any protein powder I was
just curious your opinion oh okay well
that's fair I mean you did not take my
opinion on that taco place that you said
last time
in San Diego I believe it's called is it
posto
I it was something like that but it
looked like fancy and tasty and I wanted
to try there and I couldn't remember
exactly what it was and yeah oh no I
believe it it's Puesto Puesto Puesto
okay uh fantastic tacos the brisket Taco
is hard to beat
and if you're ever in San Diego again I
highly recommend you go to Tacos El
Gordo in National City okay that is
isn't way less fancy of a place but the
autobada tacos are to die for they're
amazing beautiful all right I appreciate
the recommendation
all right all right take care very good
uh very very sub really like meaty calls
today
let's go next to is it uh Nathan from
Green Acres is that right
uh yeah that's right I can't I spoke
with you before
um a couple months ago okay
oh last time we spoke I was running for
office but uh I didn't win got 41 of the
first time candidate it's all right all
right a couple questions just two
um but first I just wanted to recommend
if you're going to use protein powder
you probably want to use it if you're
lifting just like protein powders like
if you want to get big but yeah I know I
was kidding when I asked I'm not really
looking to use protein powder
yeah yeah you look like a healthy
individual so you good thank you
um but my first question is I feel like
a lot of the momentum is changing with
the midterms I think Florida is an
excellent example of this
um
I actually noticed this and nobody's
really talking about this but in the
Democratic primary this time around
there were more people that voted than
people that voted in 2018 and that
surprised me because 2018 had more
candidates 2018 had was like supposed to
be a Blue Wave year but we have more
Democrats voting now in Florida uh we
didn't really have a real Republican
primary but I'm curious if Democrats do
well in the primary this time around or
excuse me in the midterm veteran wins in
Pennsylvania
the Democratic Senate candidate and
Wisconsin wins maybe even Val demings
and Charlie Chris win that'd be great
um that would be great but where do
Democrats go from there because they
have potentially expanded the majority
in the Senate I don't know so much about
the house I have some positive news for
the houses we have more progressives
Maxwell Alejandro Frost from Florida as
well but where do Democrats go for the
rest of the Biden Administration from
2022 to 2024. I have no idea and I
actually spoke about that with
Congressman rokana earlier in the week
because the way that Republicans are
going to function is as follows if
Democrats maintain the Senate but lose
the house which is right now the most
statistically likely outcome even though
the momentum continues to shift
Democrats will get obstructed by
Republicans on everything they do other
than Supreme Court picks if Biden gets
another Supreme Court pick they'll be
able to get it through but otherwise
Republicans are going to stand in the
way of everything and then when it comes
2024 they'll say Democrats did nothing
for you for the last two years thanks to
us but they won't say that you should
vote for a Republican and you know even
in my conversation with rokana
he said well people won't fall for that
people will know I don't know I don't
know I'm not sure about that so I think
that's a very difficult scenario and I
don't really have an answer but I think
it's a likely one
yeah yup yup yup that makes sense that
makes sense and I guess my second
question I'll try to be quick with this
one is have you ever considered speaking
at college campuses because I've done it
before I've done it before
yeah uh well would you want to do it
anytime soon uh FAU Florida so here's
the deal I'll be totally honest and
forthright with you so I I don't do it
for free right because it's usually like
three total days of travel it often
takes me away from the show whereas
which is how I make money or I lose a
weekend and especially now with a baby
at home it's really gotta be worth it
for me to do that and you know most
colleges they just don't really have the
budget
yeah 100 yeah for liberals for
conservatives they have great budget for
conservatives they'll bring in Ben
Shapiro and Michael knows and they'll
play pay out the Wazoo but for liberals
they tend not to have the budget
yeah no that's 100 reasonable I
appreciate the directness with that and
I appreciate your answer to my question
and I appreciate your content all right
thanks so much all right Nathan from
Green Acres great to hear from you we're
going to take the briefest of breaks so
if you're holding on to talk to me don't
hang up because I'm going right back to
the phones in a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
let's get back to you the audience via
Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord so that we can learn from people
let's try Steve from the bay area again
Steve you bailed on me when I went to
you at the top of the show but you are
back I'm sure now you have a great
question for me
hey David I'm really sorry about that it
was my first time calling in I got a
little nervous what didn't have a
question ready but now I do I hear it it
almost sounds do you have it written
down I thought I just heard a piece of
paper Shuffle
oh just moving a bag of food oh okay
um anyways so um I'm probably one of
those random rare people that is a
progressive and a Christian as well okay
and um I know a lot of people including
myself have a bad taste in her mouth
over the Evangelical right and uh there
are I just wanted to let you know that
there are a minority of us sadly we are
a minority that uh is fighting for you
know the actual love and of our neighbor
as as Jesus talked about so um I'm just
wondering um have you met many
Christians that like are on that side of
the progressive uh like Bernie Vibe and
and uh what's your experience with them
yeah you know I I'm I haven't met
hundreds but I've certainly met a and
know in my personal life one to two
dozen people who are progressive
Christians we've interviewed some
Progressive Christians uh yeah also
Progressive I mean I guess Progressive
Catholics is more common Catholics I
think tend to be more left than
certainly evangelicals I guess I would
say no but I know I know Born Again
Christians who are left I don't know
that they're Bernie necessarily but
they're certainly on the left and uh
soon we're actually our friend Benjamin
Dixon is doing some great work from
within Christianity to fight Christian
nationalism he's a progressive Christian
and uh yeah it's not uh it's it's not
the rarest thing in the world
yeah for sure
um I I really follow an organization
called red letter Christians and they
really try to focus on kind of the words
that Jesus said in the Bible and whether
you believe it or not and that's fine um
I know you're not particularly religious
um but you know there are those of us
out there who read the Bible for
ourselves and are like uh maybe we
should actually do those nice things and
treat people with respect and not push
our beliefs on others now we're our
Progressive Christians Like You on
abortion
um I am pro-choice interesting and what
is that scriptural justification in your
mind
um I don't think there's I don't think
the Bible even discusses abortion
honestly so it's just the Bible is a
non-issue to your view on abortion
yeah I think that overall there's more
good done to um to support abortion
rather than you know stick people that
would seek one usually for financial
reasons because they kind of you know
can support one yeah but that's about
half the time
um and why would we assume those people
should bring up children and and uh you
know saddle them with that kind of
burden and stuff so and most of them
happen in the first trimester anyways
when I don't really think that's a life
I mean it makes a lot of sense to me and
then how about on gay marriage
uh my brother's gay so and he's married
and um I mean I guess if I if I was
pressured I'm probably like you know
anti-gay marriage personally but like I
would vote against it I guess
um and I love my brother and I support
him and I know that probably sounds bad
too like you wouldn't get a gay marriage
but you're okay with other people doing
it yeah well I like I like girls but um
right no but I I understand I also have
a lot of empathy for people who do have
attraction to the same sex because I
know if I was in that situation it would
be really tough and I I don't know if I
if I how I would square that with my
faith so interesting I'd have to uh
personally figure it out you you I'm
guessing from what you're saying you
don't think people choose to be gay
no definitely not yeah yeah all right
well very interesting I appreciate your
insights
all right thank you all right there we
go Progressive Christians very very
interesting
uh all right let's let's keep talking to
people why not right I mean we're all
here let's go to where are we going here
uh oh I don't know why don't we go to
our friend attack from Denmark it's been
a while since we've spoken welcome back
hello hello can you hear me I can hear
you fine
awesome yeah no one of the reasons why
I've actually been gone for so long is
because I was actually in the military
for the past couple months oh wow basic
training so yeah that's the Danish
military
what is basic training like in Denmark
uh it's um so it's it's four months
total
um so basically if you go through all
the basic threads like you start out
with
um Fury and so forth you um go for
things like how do you move as a unit uh
there's also a lot of physical training
stuff like that and then the final part
of it you basically uh take part in a
lot of kinds of exercise things where
you have to simulate attacks and enemy
positions and so forth so it's a it's a
whole thing basically but yeah this is
something you chose to do
yes there is conscription in Denmark
um I was not conscripted however I'm I
volunteered um I am planning on becoming
an officer in the Army soon enough
um especially as I you know recently
finished my studies in the University so
this is my uh next thing basically
interesting and is that in Denmark is
that a good career
as an officer in the military absolutely
interesting um and one of the greatest
things about
officer actually is the um the training
you get to the leadership training is
one of the most uh attractive ones in
Denmark and you can use it outside of
the military as well and so my specific
goal is to become a language officer
where I will focus on interviewing an
interpreter basically with a special
focus on Russian and Ukrainian as the
languages I'm going to be using oh wow
what languages do you speak
I speak Danish German English and very
basic Russian currently okay so your
Russian would have to improve to be able
to do that
the language offices training program is
you go through a language course that's
one of the big things it's a two to
three year course that you go through
and after that you basically are fully
qualified officer and then you get sent
out on deployment for uh a year and a
half after which you can work on a
contract basically and is uh is the this
is my last question and then we can get
to your question is the military in
Denmark
similar into the U.S in that there is
lots of sort of like uh toxic masculine
Alpha type stuff that goes on or is it
different in that sense
so this is actually super interesting
um the Danish military is very much so
not like that at least not anymore one
thing I can tell you is that when you
see a lot of those videos if you know
U.S Trail instructors what do you know
yelling at the soldiers and stuff like
that yeah
doesn't happen to Danish military at
least not in my experience if you screw
up they will come over to you and say oh
well you did that wrong go and do it
again please right like that instead of
saying you idiot what are you doing blah
blah blah you know you see like what
else some of those American like
documentaries on the US military yeah
that's quite different that's quite
different you'll find toxic masculinity
in there absolutely but there are a lot
of women as well in the Danish Armed
Forces actually in my course
um I think about a quarter of a stair
were actually women which was you know
super interesting that is interesting
that is interesting well listen I've
taken up so much of your time I'm
guessing you had a question maybe I
don't know
yes I actually did have a question
that was actually I wanted to ask you
about
um
I know that like the Ukraine war hasn't
been a very big thing recently on the
show and not been talked a lot about a
lot recently but um as of currently
um the Ukrainian uh Ward you know it's
almost in a kind of standstill and so
forth yes
um front lines aren't really moving a
lot there is an offensive working
towards care so I'm currently from the
Ukrainian side and so my question is do
you think as the public perception of
the War Winds down in the west as we
don't focus on it as much anymore over
domestic issues like Energy prices and
so forth do you think that Western
support will continue being as strong as
it has been up has been up until now I
think government support will but I
think average you know Ukrainian Flags
in the streets is diminishing
yeah I would definitely agree with that
I think that a big a big problem that I
see is that people think because public
perception goes down that government
support will go down as well but I think
that we've seen during the war in
Afghanistan for instance that we haven't
constantly heard about Afghanistan 24 7
for 20 years right when we were still
over there you know Denmark was also in
Afghanistan for instance yes but just
because it's not in the news doesn't
mean that support will die down because
there's obviously geopolitical interest
at play here that I don't think the us
or the EU wants to get rid of just
because people don't really want to hear
about it that much anymore 100 I agree
with you yeah I don't I don't think that
the government support will diminish
and so my next question is do you think
that it uh makes sense for the United
States for instance to start training
the Ukrainian military on more advanced
weapon systems such as Western fighter
jets and so forth which is well I think
the answer is yes with the asterisk of
do they have those systems and if not
who's going to give them to them that's
the obviously there would be little
sense in doing the training if they're
not going to have access to those
systems and or who gives them to them
yeah and that was something that I saw
was being discussed in Congress recently
was they wanted to start supplying f-15s
to Ukraine after they started training
Ukrainian pilots in them so which is
interesting because you know when we
look at the Ukrainian military we see a
military that has been in many ways you
know influenced by the Soviet Union up
until 2015 around when the donbass war
started yes indeed and in many ways NATO
the Us and other Western countries are
trying really hard currently to
reintegrate the Ukrainian military from
using a large part Soviet equipment to
using more Western Equipment yes and
seeing like the way that it's been
escalating slowly but but steadily from
you know supplying anti-tank weapons in
the very beginning of the war to now
supplying air defense systems missiles
for Ukrainian Jets I think it's a super
interesting development that like we
don't really know where it's going to
end but I think it's really interesting
to focus on that and how the Ukrainian
military is going to transform as this
war goes on it could be a dramatically
different military if this does extend
into the years as many predict it will
the Ukrainian military could end up
coming out of this completely
differently and then then it went in and
it is interesting to say the least
appreciate the call thank you
thank you too all right very very
important stuff let's see if we can
squeeze in more people let's go to is it
Des desmu or Desmond from Birmingham
desmu Desmond
you're on the air
hey what's up can you hear me fine yes I
can
cool cool okay awesome
um so I had a question but I'm not sure
if it's like better to like preface my
question with some like a context first
probably not let's get the question
first and I'll tell you if we need
context
okay okay cool okay
um do you think that con Subs like
um let me think of a good example of an
adjective okay it's fine I guess that's
not important do you think that Concepts
uh like um
social welfare policies uh I guess I
don't know if this is the correct
category to put that in but things like
uh
uh Universal like single-payer
healthcare or like public more
affordable like colleges Universal like
public colleges and stuff like that
Concepts like that that are obviously a
lot more like commonplace within like
Europe do you think that things like
that are
kind of completely lost on the US
no lost in what sense
and kind of like um
like for example like I live in
Birmingham Alabama and if I tell someone
around here
that I think um Universal single player
Healthcare is cool and then I think that
you know public college is cool there
they might call me a satanic communist
or something like that you know what I
mean yeah I mean listening
yeah I know that's that of oh there are
people who may be against these things
for fiscal reasons or whatever the case
may be but very few are going to say
that you're a satanic communist because
of your you're favoring that so no I
don't think it's lost on people at all
and in fact I would argue that because
of people's increased understanding of
the ways in which they are getting
screwed even if they don't understand
who's screwing them I think that it's
actually a great environment now to be
talking more about the fact that these
are just basic not controversial parts
of many Western countries economies and
societies uh my friend I gotta run I
appreciate the call there's Desmond from
Birmingham I apologize I cannot take any
more calls today but we will take more
calls in the future
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's get
to the most important bag which is the
mailbag you can email info
davidpackman.com on Fridays we will
feature
some but not nearly all I mean listen we
get thousands of messages a week we will
feature some of the messages that come
in info davidpackman.com compliments
welcome of course questions uh
prioritized criticisms received and then
trolling more or less ignored but not
always let's start with the first
message this one is from Ben and it is
about George Soros Ben says hello David
is it true that you are being funded by
George Soros I have heard that in South
Korea my country George Soros said an
international Jewish cabal are trying to
destroy the country by funding Mass
immigration and low birth rates in order
to achieve world domination is this true
you know it's not true and there's a
couple things going on here first of all
George Soros is 92 years old I think
that at this point even if at one point
he had his heart set on global dominate
domination uh through low birth rates
and all these different things that take
decades if not longer to do I think at
this point he's probably done with that
plan he is now 92 years old and most
importantly no I am not funded by George
Soros not funded by George Soros not
funded by the DNC not funded by whoever
you think we're funded by I'm funded by
people in the audience probably not like
Ben
but people in the audience who value
what we do and choose to support it Paul
wrote in and says your stated opinion in
past episodes on YouTube was that you
were doubtful Trump would ever be
prosecuted for the crimes he's committed
in light of recent events at various
Court proceedings and particularly the
stealing of classified information have
you now revised your opinion thank you I
have and as I've said before I would
love to be wrong on this I now believe
that Donald Trump is likely to be
indicted and not likely to serve even a
single day behind bars that's my current
opinion and as many of you might know if
you watch the show at all regularly I
revise my opinions as information
becomes available and I think that
that's a great thing to do it's
something that should be encouraged and
I now believe Trump will be indicted no
prison time
curious to hear from you your thoughts
Paul wrote in about student loan
forgiveness
Paul says David I know many see the
student loan relief as a good thing but
I see problems with it
I will say that I'm happy that it seems
well targeted only ten thousand dollars
to people earning under 125 000. my
issue with it is that it's a Band-Aid
and it sets a precedent it may help
people with debt now but it won't
convince next year students to think
twice before taking out large loans that
they can't afford and we'll be right
back in the same place people will be
clamoring for another round of student
loan relief in five years younger
siblings will say my older sister got
relief now it's my turn this can't
become an ongoing expectation wouldn't
this money be better spent trying to
make education more affordable for
future and current students rather than
forgiving loans for people who already
agreed to pay them off for giving the
interest so the debt doesn't keep
growing but keeping the principal is
also a great idea that I've heard others
mention curious to hear your thoughts
could show yeah I've addressed this
the student loan debt relief won't do
anything to put downward pressure on the
price of college and university and
higher education and we need to do that
the system is broken the system is
broken we I was calculating the other
day if uh prices continue increasing
over the next 18 years by the time my
daughter would go to college
the college that my girlfriend went to
would cost two hundred and six thousand
dollars a year right so you're talking
like 850k for four years
is is that possible or is does that
sound like something's broken so
absolutely something needs to change and
just a little a sprinkling of student
loan debt relief isn't going to do it
and so this is two different problems
it's one problem the system is broken
but there's two different parts to it
existing debt and doing something about
the cost of college what Joe Biden does
does something about existing debt it
doesn't deal with the cost of college we
need at minimum free Community College
if tons of people who would go to a
four-year school and take on four years
of debt say hey you know what I'll do my
first two years for free at Community
College if that happens demand for the
four-year schools will go down and those
schools will have to if they want to
increase the number of people who are
interested and willing to go uh they're
gonna have to decrease prices that's
it's one idea and there's many others
um another idea which is controversial
to some is make it more difficult to get
the loans if it's more difficult to just
get a loan for 400k to go wherever you
want for whatever degree
if it becomes more difficult that would
put downward pressure so I'm with you
100 Paul this doesn't deal with the
second issue it only deals with the debt
and we need to be dealing with both
Clint wrote in about Hillary Clinton I
don't know what the hell Clint's talking
about here maybe you can help me figure
it out Clint writes David I follow you
and listen to you regularly I have to
tell you Hillary's not running in 2024.
I never said she was I worked for her
campaign in 2008 and 2016. the majority
of her staff myself included are
positioning ourselves for Pete bootage
you can correct me if I'm wrong if
you're going to say anything about
Hillary at least speak positive well
listen Clint I will sometimes say
positive things about Hillary and
sometimes I will say negative things
about Hillary I will say whatever I want
about Hillary on the show but in terms
of
she's not running and speak I don't know
what you're talking about Clint I never
said Hillary was running I did do a
story a couple of months ago indicating
that there are high level Democratic
party people talking about Hillary
running again I didn't say it was former
you know lower level staff or anything
like that but uh Clint maybe the message
was meant for someone else I don't know
but uh we'll see if we can figure out
about it Chris wrote in and asked is
losing better
David do you think it may be becoming a
republican strategy to lose just enough
elections to not have a majority power
in the Senate but still have enough
seats to filibuster major legislation
and this could apply to the White House
in 2024 as well my point is they seem to
enjoy being able to criticize everything
Democrats do and they don't really have
any policies to speak of Mitch McConnell
always talks about his main objective is
to win elections but maybe not what do
you think well I've addressed this in a
very specific way which is
Republicans in 2024
want to make the case that Biden should
be replaced with a republican because he
didn't get anything done
and so Republicans want to ensure that
Biden and Democrats don't get anything
done and a great way to do that is to
have divided Congress Democrats
controlling the Senate and Republicans
controlling the house it's a great way
for in the lead up to the 24 election
Republicans to be able to say look
they've had the White House for four
years they've had the senate for four
years and when's the last time they got
anything done and of course there would
be that two-year stretch where nothing
gets done because Republicans control
the house so I don't know about the
bigger picture Chris of just never get
anything done and but I think in the
immediate that's exactly their goal with
Joe Biden and Democrats over the next
two years
um Terry Rhoden and said you messaged me
and I'm going to keep doing this for as
long as I have to Terry said David I was
watching your YouTube show last night
and I got two messages that appeared to
be from you it was WhatsApp and it said
write me I don't use WhatsApp I've never
tweeted and I certainly have never
Instagram crackered anything keep on
rocking brother yeah so listen I am not
trying to DM or Whatsapp anybody in the
audience okay there are rampant scammers
on our YouTube channel and they will put
my face imagine that this face they put
my face as their profile image and they
respond to people in the comments and
they say hey I'd love to chat with you
directly please WhatsApp me DM me hear
this that the other thing and it's a
scam they want to steal your money okay
we report them to YouTube as fast as we
can you can report them to YouTube say
that they are impersonating uh me and
YouTube will ban them but it's like
whack-a-mole okay so I'm not trying to
contact anyone
the only time I am in touch with viewers
is when they call in when we take calls
all right so not me don't fall for it
Jeffrey asks should we leave the country
this is a sad situation Jeffrey says
I've been concerned for a while now that
if an autocrat is elected in 24 it may
be time to really consider leaving the
US and moving to a country that has a
stable democracy through my work I could
get a Visa in a Scandinavian country and
or my wife has dual citizenship in
Australia I think it's important for my
children to live in a safe free country
and I'm concerned we could be seeing the
end of such a country here in the U.S
leaving the country has always seemed
like a drastic step to me but it seems
it's becoming more of a reality what do
you think well you know every time this
comes up people get mad at me they say
David
you're dripping with privilege when you
talk about this it is a reality
that I was born in Argentina
so if I needed to go to another country
I could go back to Argentina it's and by
the way if you look at the economic
situation and who's in power right now
down there it's it's no it's no dream to
be down there okay but it's something
all right as an individual of the Jewish
persuasion as who was it that said that
I don't remember anyway I'm Jewish I
could go through a process I believe it
takes a year or two to get citizenship
in Israel and yes because my family is
originally from Western Europe and fled
right before the Holocaust Poland has a
program where I could request
citizenship because my grandfather was
from Poland
I'm working on it I still don't have the
documents I need to do that so yeah I'm
I'm working on a backup plan for sure
now am I in this like I'm moving to
Canada if DeSantis wins in 24. now first
of all it's really hard to move to
Canada I don't know how many of you have
looked into it but um no I'm not saying
that but what I would say Jeffrey is
you are going to do what is best for
your family
and so I would have the plan in place
why not give yourself options and then
if the time should come
you can Avail yourself of those options
what else can I say
Noah Roden
and said David do you think Donald Trump
will be indicted and sentenced for the
rest of his life no I don't I do believe
at this point increasingly that it is
likely Trump will be indicted
I don't think Trump's going to do a
single day behind bars
opening that one up to the rest of you
if you believe Trump is going to do
prison time any at all write in info
davidpackman.com leave a YouTube comment
send a tweet leave a Facebook message
respond to me on Truth Central whatever
I don't believe he will do a single day
uh we have a great bonus show for you
today you can sign up for the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad yeah all right uh
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code big voting22 to get a discount and
I will either see you on the bonus show
or once we return from the Labor Day
long weekend
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors I protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
Aura I get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so I can fix the problem
fast try Aura free for two weeks using
my link below